the aim of Monday's meeting in Moscow
was to formalize the cease fire that
started in Libya on Sunday 24 hours
earlier Russia and Turkey invited Fayed
al Suraj Prime Minister of the un-backed
government and warlord Khalifa Haftar to
sign a more permanent truth that's aimed
at paving the way towards formal
negotiations to end
Libya's nine year-long civil war but
after seven hours of talks one signature
remains missing Jordan a memo from the
was reached today we can report that a
certain progress has been achieved and
the chairman of the government of
national Accord of Libya mr. Siraj and
the chairman of hive Council of State
mr. McCree has just signed it marshal
shaft are the comment of Libyan National
Army and the president of Libyan House
of Representatives in Tobruk mr. Aguilar
salic see this document positively and
have asked for some extra time till
tomorrow morning to decide on whatever
to sign it I hope their decision will be
positive the ceasefire was brokered by
the president of Turkey and Russia in
Istanbul last week following a meeting
with Italy's Prime Minister is a picante
red chip type a1 announced he will be in
Berlin on January the 19th for an
international conference aimed at ending
the Libyan conflict you know boletos
apology : even if it is only in one day
I believe a strong result with emerge
from these talks the talks which take
place in Moscow today lay the foundation
for the Berlin process Turkish troops
were recently sent to Libya to help slow
haft us 9-month advance on the capital
tripoli in the complicated proxy war
russian mercenaries together with the
United Arab Emirates and Egypt are
aiding after both Russia and Turkey say
they are hopeful that hafta will sign
the truth agreement on Tuesday morning
the long and complicated negotiations
here in Moscow show how complicated the
conflict in Libya is with the
international conference jus in Berlin
it's crucial that the truth agreement
will be signed and sealed here in Moscow
first step fasten al-jazeera
Moscow